en hamburgo él está en un terreno
conquistado olaf scholz el candidato
socialdemócrata a la cancillería fue
alcalde de esa ciudad entre 2011 y 2018
es un placer volver de saber es algo que
reconforta el corazón olaf scholz tienen
razones para sonreír es el favorito de
los alemanes
fondas esta confianza que los alemanes
me entregan me conmueve muchas voces
esto da alas al partido spd que viene
perdiendo terreno en alemania desde hace
20 años solo hamburgo permanece como un
fiel bastión es aquí en el puerto
industrial más grande del país en donde
nació el socialismo alemán en medio de
la lucha de clases del siglo 19 por eso
en el bar del puerto en donde los
marineros obreros y estibadores se
encuentran cada día hay mucha decepción
por el spd
antes el spd era un partido para los
obreros pero eso se acabó hace mucho
tiempo el partido perdió completamente
el contacto con su base electoral
hamburgo ya no vota por convicción según
el dueño de este bar y
aquí votamos por el spd por tradición
también puede ser que nos hayamos dado
cuenta que los otros partidos son aún
peores que el spd y fiestas y andan nov
las tasas
después de haber liberalizado el mercado
laboral en los años 2000 y haber
participado en gobiernos de la mano de
los conservadores y el spd ha perdido su
identidad es un desafío para los
candidatos a las elecciones legislativas
como falco grossman y sus militantes
entre otras cosas hemos impuesto la
jubilación mínima y las ayudas a la
formación la política del gobierno ha
estado marcada por los socialdemócratas
pero es difícil hacer que los electores
lo entiendan de inversionistas por tanto
gracias a la popularidad de su candidato
el spd tiene de nuevo todas las opciones
de integrar el nuevo futuro alemán